what's going on guys this is rob and
with thor coming out this week i felt
like it'd be a cool idea to at the very
least just create a bunch of thor
content and beta ray bill has kind of
been a big talking point for the thor
mythos in the mcu for quite some time
whether it's easter eggs or different
things like that and so i feel like if
ever we were going to see beta ray bill
in the mcu now would be it
[Laughter]
i don't know that we will but i think
it'd be cool if we did and so i figured
on the off chance that he does appear
i'd make a video called vader a bill
explained plus just a cool thing to do
and we've never done it before um so
beta ray bill first appeared in marvel
comics with thor issue number 337 in
1983 and he was created by walt simonsen
now if you talk to anybody out there who
is a fan of thor comics and has been
reading them for quite some time they
will likely tell you that vader ray bill
is one of the most important and one of
the most well-known members of the thor
mythos although probably in the last
couple decades he's sort of fallen out
of prominence and is really feels like
an aging character then we'll talk about
why over the course this video but there
was a really good interview that walt
simonsen had done with daniel warren
johnson which was published on
marvel.com where he outlined why it was
he made beta ray bill in the first place
and one of the things to know is that
creating comics are coming on as a comic
book creator in marvel comics really in
the 70s and 80s was a relatively easy
thing to do um all you really had to do
was just kind of send in a series of
scripts or maybe some artwork or
something like that and it wasn't too
difficult for you to get hired on
because at the time despite their
success with a lot of characters they
had created marvel was still just like a
hotbed of all sorts of creative content
and they were really just looking for
people to create content for them in
recent years right now like in the
modern era it's notoriously difficult to
get a job working at marvel comics as an
artist or a writer just because of the
sheer number of people out there who
were trying to do it but that number was
much smaller back in the 70s and 80s for
walt simonsen when he was at amherst
which is an art school one he had
actually been reading comics for quite
some time and had been crafting a bit of
a story that dealt with certain albeit
behind the scenes but he had also
considered this idea of having somebody
out there or writing an arc in relation
to the thor mythos that simply just
hadn't been done before and so when he
was brought on as a writer and artist
for marvel comics one of the first
things he did was set about basically
bringing this story to fruition and one
of the things that had never happened in
the history of thor mythos up to that
point in time especially considering all
the work that had been done by stan lee
jack kirby the old journey into mystery
stories the tales of asgard stories
there had never been anybody out there
who had ever picked up the hammer of
thor and been able to use it that it
just never happened and so walt simonson
saw this as a chance to one not only
turn the thor mythos or turn the thor
comics into something that was wholly
his but also just make a statement with
the beginning of his store run and
that's exactly what happened so one of
the things to know about the origin of
beta ray bill is that it hasn't really
changed drastically over the years in
marvel comics and for a lot of
characters it is like that right for a
lot of origins and marvel comics you
don't really see huge drastic changes
but while while being rebuilt's origin
has been told and retold several times
in the end it is just a retelling of the
origin that we got in thor
337-339 and what we ended up finding out
here is that there is a place in the
universe that's referred to as the
burning galaxy now with regards to beta
ray bill and the corbin's right the
corbinite race this was just a
quintessential example of just being in
the wrong place at the wrong time
so the idea of surter who a lot of you
guys are familiar with it for no other
reason than uh thor ragnarok but
basically he's prophesized to use the
twilight sword to bring about ragnarok
or the end of the asgardians that the
burning galaxy was a place where cerner
wanted to create his twilight sword and
so because the corbins were home to this
uh this galaxy when sutter and his fire
demons invaded the corbins had no choice
but to flee and so they started building
a whole bunch of ships i mean like
thousands of ships uh they ended up
basically freezing most members of their
race because there weren't enough
resources to feed them all and keep them
all alive for the journey that was being
undergone but bill himself had undergone
a process of cybernetic augmentation to
where he was effectively enhanced and if
there was some kind of an emergency
instance that required the protection of
the corbonite race while they were
traveling to their new world that bill
would be activated and that's exactly
what happened that along the journey
following the destruction of his racist
planet and their journey to a new world
that he ended up coming coming across
earth now this was an instance back then
when you saw a lot more crossover
between comic book characters than you
do now nowadays when you look at coming
back crossovers take for example
christopher cantwell's iron man run you
do see some crossover there but it's by
and large part of the main story arc
itself it's not one of those things
where a character appears momentarily
and they're there to just kind of set
the story in motion and then go from
there and even the different crossovers
that you see in a lot of ways are
confined to like smaller characters it's
not always that way but it's not quite
the same as it was in the 1980s in this
instance what you had was nick fury as
director of shield that he had come
across or they had picked up on what was
basically a spaceship not knowing
anything about it and so what he did is
he dispatched thor to basically check it
out and when thor arrived on the scene
beta ray bill was activated because the
ship's scuttlebutt i know it's a weird
name but the ship's scuttlebutt
determined that thor was an enemy not
knowing what thor was and simply because
he was literally showing up with a
weapon and so what this did is it led to
a conflict breaking out between the two
now ultimately thor lost his hammer
mjolnir and this was back in the time in
the thor mythos where if he was removed
from his hammer for you know 60 seconds
or so he would revert back to donald
blake and that's what happened that
effectively thor had been his hammer had
been knocked away from him he had lost
possession of it and he reverted to
donald blake and in doing so beta ray
bill knocked him out following that beta
ray bill picked up the hammer of thor
and basically became the the first
person to do so but also set the
standard that anybody in the future
whoever picks up the hammer of thor for
any real measure of time meaning they
fulfill the enchantment of being worthy
they'll basically end up taking on the
traditional thor garb but it'll be
modified to fit their appearance and
with beta ray bill being the first
person to do that it totally changed
everything when this story came out it
was landmark i mean even to this day
it's still one of the most significant
stories in the history of the thor
mythos because it's the first person
other than thor to pick his hammer up
but regardless of how you slice it the
reality here was walt simonson wanted to
craft this story that kept the reader
just glued to everything going on and so
what happened is that following this the
question was who gets to wield milner
right is if there was a hammer that was
created by by odin and has always
belonged to thor however suddenly
somebody comes along and was able to
pick up the hammer and use it for their
own ends and with beta ray bill
believing that thor was an enemy simply
just considered it his reward for having
defeated thor fans wanted to know was
thor being replaced and so what ended up
happening is odin brought the two
together and had them face off against
one another in a fight to the death and
whoever it was that came out on top
would ultimately be the victor would be
the person that would wield mjolnir from
that point going forward now of course
we know in hindsight thor didn't die but
that was because vader ray bill chose
not to kill him but it was one of those
instances where bill had overpowered
thor twice and so what you ended up
getting here was basically walt simonsen
establishing beta ray bill as not only
the first person to lift thor's hammer
but somebody who could actually defeat
thor who was more capable than thor was
and so as a result of that it was a
prime spot for marvel to start shopping
beta ray bill around and so with beta
ray bill getting his own hammer in the
form of stormbreaker which was basically
forged out of uru right the same metal
that was used to make mjolnir it was a
chance to showcase what this guy was
capable of now one of the things to know
about walt simonsen's run is that while
this particular story is one of the most
significant stories of his run it was
not the main focus it wasn't the main
effort of walt simonsen to simply just
introduce somebody who could lift thor's
hammer and then that was kind of like
okay well it's all downhill from here
that walt simonson's main focus was
always the character of certain going
all the way back to his days when he was
at amherst learning the the art of
comics and so on and so forth he had
always wanted to transform certa from
the old school jack kirby stan lee
comics into somebody who was a
legitimate incredible threat and could
actually lead to the destruction of
asgard itself so while you did see
malikith and other characters introduced
this all came to a head in thor issues
350 the 353 in what we call the surter
saga now for beta ray bill again the
main focus of this video this story is
particularly important because with him
basically being given stormbreaker and
with the asgardians helping him to
defeat the fire demons of cerner saving
the corbinite race giving the corporate
race the ability to find a new world
which became new corbin this story
actually began to give us the form in
which betty ray bill's role in marvel
comics would basically take and that
what you saw with the surter saga was
basically thor gathering all his allies
together and them helping to face off
against the forces of certain preventing
ragnarok but you also ended up seeing
like certain odin fall into a giant
chasm and that kind of seemed to be the
end of them and so on and so forth but
what this did is it set the stage that
going forward in the future of marvel
comics while beta ray bill wasn't
necessarily some kind of unnecessary
background character in the thor mythos
he was never the main star of the thor
comics and that was one of the things
that fans kind of found a little
disappointing if you go back and you
read the letters pages at marvel carly's
coming into the thor comics for marvel
at the time while fans didn't
necessarily expect some kind of like
batman and robin type team up regarding
thor and beta ray bill what they didn't
expect is bad ray bill would kind of
fall to the background and so in order
to combat this idea that beta ray bill
felt like he was kind of becoming a bit
unnecessary that what marvel started
doing was basically shopping him around
at different comic books and so what you
saw is that in october of 1985 he was
introduced in power pack issue number 15
teaming up with the members of the power
pack team now while that story was
geared largely towards kids it is
important because it's one of the first
stories really in over the course of two
years when beta ray bill was basically
removed from the thor comics are not
really removed but taken out of the thor
comics and actually placed in another
comic book one of the issues to come out
of this though is that with walt
simonson's run officially ending with
thor vol 1 issue number 382 this led to
a guy named tom defalco writing the thor
comics now depending on who you talk to
some people may say they loved tom
defalco's run others say it's uh it's
okay i mean he did have some iconic
stories for example thor alone against
the celestials but for beta ray bill
there wasn't really anything doing here
and in fact beta ray bill disappeared
from marvel comics in its entirety for
about three years between 1986 with thor
issue number 372 and 1989 and thor issue
411 he was gone now eventually he did
return but at the end of the day marvel
wasn't really entirely sure what to do
with him because tom defalco's handling
of thor was not really as much a
successor of walt simonsen's run as it
was a spiritual successor of the old
stan lee and jack kirby days so kind of
taking thor back to that method of
storytelling what this meant is that in
1993 marvel had the idea of at least
temporarily or trying to remove beta ray
bill from the thor comics entirely
keeping him intact insofar as he had
stormbreaker he looked like thor and
then actually making him more of a
cosmic character and so while he did
team up in the four-issue mini-series by
tom defalco called thor core which was
really the first iteration of it for
those of you guys who are familiar with
the thor core stories from uh secret
wars the whole secret wars event um the
reality here is that in 1995 under mark
gruenwald marvel commissioned a story
that basically focused on a group called
the star masters that largely dealt with
the idea that quasar wendell vaughn had
been framed the star masters were there
to basically prove his innocence things
along those lines but the reality here
is that despite the fact that the team
was interesting in the sense that you
had vader ray bill you had morphex
quasar you had silver surfer zenith the
reality is that it was almost kind of
the unsellables to a degree right it was
characters who were at one point
exceedingly popular who were considered
legacy characters whose name still
carried weight in the case of uh quasar
especially during that point in time
following the work of uh greg capullo as
artists for those of you guys who don't
know before he was drawing batman
grecopulo did the quasar comics back in
the 1990s um but also having silver
surfer whose name always draws attention
hence the reason he was put on the team
the reality here is that people just
weren't really receptive to it uh
anybody out there who was familiar with
beta ray bill and really his core
audience they saw him as a thor
character and they wanted him to be a
thor character they didn't really want
him to be deviated away or removed from
the thor mythos and so while there was
an attempt by marvel to bring him back
to the thor mythos temporarily the
reality here is they kept chopping him
around and the reason why is because in
the mid 1990s one of the things we've
talked about before marvel was in the
face of going belly up right the coming
bus to the mid-1990s people who were
previously buying comics under the
belief that they would be worth a
fortune in the future stopped buying
comics because they realized that there
were so many of those comics made they
weren't going to be worth as much as
they were before uh and so that almost
killed marvel comics had it not been for
her mudder and and aviarad they would
have gone belly up but the truth about
this is that for beta ray bill he was
considered a holdover from the walt
simonsen days and marvel just couldn't
really write compelling stories about
him and didn't quite know where to put
him and so between 1996 with cosmic
powers unlimited running all the way up
to 2001 with a maximum security you saw
beta ray bill appearing in those stories
and having a role in those stories but
the truth about it is that for a lot of
readers it felt like the days of walt
simonsen and the idea of beta ray bill
being a significant character had
basically just vanished in thor volume 2
by dan jurgens with issues 33 going into
39 through 41 you did see beta ray bill
make some appearances here but again
there wasn't a whole lot doing but all
this changed in 2004 with a story called
thor disassembled now the reason why
this story happened and the significance
of this story is that in truth beta ray
bill wasn't the only character who was
suffering right the launch of event
publications with jimmy palmiotti and
joe casada running that show was really
a response to the fact that with marvel
going broke they couldn't necessarily
publish unsellable characters through
traditional means why pay top dollar to
have writers and artists create comics
about like vader a bill or daredevil if
they knew it wasn't going to sell that
well it would quite literally be a loss
they'd spend more money publishing the
comic than they would making money
selling the comic and so that's why
event publications was there it was a
cheaper way to publish comic books for
characters that weren't going to have a
very high financial turnover as we've
talked about in the past this led to uh
joe casada coming on as editor-in-chief
in 2000 and 2001 at marvel comics and it
was basically a fire sale it was a
wholesale just reworking of the marvel
comics mythos the marriage between peter
parker and mary jane watson was
nullified in spider-man one more day the
uh the x-men team or the x-men really
the mutant population was reduced down
to 198 in the aftermath of house of m i
mean it was just it was a slaughterhouse
in a lot of ways when it came to just
characters and teams that people had
become familiar with and beta ray bill
oddly enough was not one of those who
was axed but instead in the eyes of
comic book fans saw this huge resurgence
in popularity and the reason for that is
that with thor disassembled it was
basically ragnarok it was the long
overdue story that fans have been
expecting for decades really since the
walt simonsen run that basically saw the
death of thor and the asgardians and the
entire mythos that went with it and so
while beta ray bill's role in this story
was not highly significant he was really
just there alongside captain america and
uh and iron man fighting alongside the
forces of loki and sutter and those guys
in the midst of the ragnarok event what
it did is it led to marvel bringing
michael ohming back who had wrote thor
disassembled and having him craft a
story called stormbreaker the saga of
beta ray bilf and in a lot of ways
stormbreaker was as much a philosophical
story about beta ray bill as it was your
typical comic book story i mean in truth
that's unavoidable right i mean this
story dealt with like asteroth it dealt
with alfa ray who was basically the kind
of precursor or supposed to be a
successor to beta ray bill the idea that
the uh the the new corbin's believed
that beta ray bill was spending too much
time with the asgardians and basically
ignoring his own people galactus was
involved there was all kinds of stuff
that went on there right you saw your
typical comic book story the larger
picture here and really with more focus
on beta ray bill than anything else the
story dealt with a couple different
things the first was the question of
vader ray bill's place in the in the
bigger landscape now that you basically
had the entire asgardian race which had
been annihilated the second thing to be
asked here is was beta ray bill really
more asgardian than he was corbin
because he had spent so much time among
the asgardian race and the third is that
beta ray bill was kind of the last
holdout of the asgardian mythos it was
really michael ohming in them answering
that question by basically having him
engage in this final confrontation with
asteroth using what was by all standards
of measurement the god blast of thor and
then essentially destroying himself as
well as asteroth in the process quelling
the threat but almost seeming to wrap up
the entirety of beta ray bill as a
character in marvel comics now of course
we know that wasn't necessarily the case
and that didn't really last i mean quite
literally beta ray bill woke up in issue
number five in a homeless veteran's body
so by the end of that story i mean he
was back and alive and well but the
reason why this matters so much is
because whenever historically it came to
characters in marvel comics that weren't
really sellable marvel didn't really
know what to do with them it would
almost kind of be forced they would put
them on this team or that team and they
would basically force readers to try to
be you know to become acclimated to that
character with vader ray bill it was a
very different approach what marvel did
is that instead of forcing bill onto
particular teams or forcing marvel
comics readers to become acclimated to
him on different teams or in different
scenarios the stories of beta ray bill
when he appeared in like omega flight
and so on and so forth it was really
marvel just trying to
relate to the fans through beta ray bill
where fans didn't know what role beta
ray bill had the stories of beta ray
bill mirrored that he was quite
literally just out there in the world
trying to figure out what his greater
role is now right with her not being a
thor no asgard nothing like that nobody
had any idea what any of this meant and
so what you got was him involved as part
of the initiative which was basically
the story arc that took place after
civil war that where the civil war
stories were predicated on the idea of
the superhero initiative the the
50-state initiative that kind of a thing
superheroes had to register themselves
with like the us government and so on
because arguably the bad guys won
and uh the 50 state initiative went
through he was part of that as far as
omega flight went you saw him as part of
the secret invasion event but once thor
and the asgardians had returned because
a lot of those stories in the early days
of of j michael cerzinski's run dealt a
lot with thor restoring asgard bringing
back the different asgardians different
things along those lines focusing
heavily a lot on the thor concepts in
relation to like female loki and so on
and so forth literally rebuilding that
mythos beta ray bill was not really an
unnecessary character so much as he was
a character that was kind of at least
the way the stories were being told
finding his own path in marvel comics so
what you got in 2009 was a three-part
series referred to or known as beta ray
bill god hunter and this was a
phenomenal story and the reason why is
because this story was basically just a
continuation of storm breaker the saga
of beta ray bill there were some things
that happened in between that added to
the vader ray bill mythos but in truth
it was just kind of almost picking up
immediately after or relatively soon
after the events of of stormbreaker and
so what this saw was that in
stormbreaker the saga of beta ray bill
galactus had actually destroyed like
consumed and destroyed new corbin this
was basically beta ray bill's revenge
story but again it was very much a
philosophical story in the sense that
there was a point in that comic when
when silver surfer appeared to beta ray
bill and said you know you cannot defeat
galactus why are you doing this in the
first place and the reality is that it
was really just vader rayville
experiencing an existential crisis yes a
lot of him was angry at the fact that
galactus had destroyed uh new corbin and
he wasn't necessarily on a suicide
mission but it was one of those things
where he's like i don't know what else i
have i don't know what else i'm supposed
to do or where i'm supposed to go i
don't have as guardians anymore my
people are gone i don't know like i have
no idea what it is that's supposed to be
happening here right who am i in all of
this where am i going what am i doing
what's my place in this bigger picture
now what was so great about this is that
while eventually he saved galactus from
another race that goliath was basically
being attacked by and he was rewarded
with a mate of his own that marvel
actually leaned into this over the
course of donnie kate's guardians of the
galaxy vol 5 this was the main focus
right the stories that came after that
it was all just a main focus that beta
ray bill was just free floating through
the through the universe so as opposed
to it being one of those situations
where we would say vader ray bill was
free-floating because marvel didn't know
what to do with him it was one of those
beta ray bill's free floating because
marvel's crafting stories that fit his
current state in marvel comics where he
doesn't really seem to belong anywhere
occasionally he would show up and he
would fight alongside thor you would see
him out there on other teams but with
asgard and his people having previously
been obliterated and beta ray bill
having gone through this sort of
spiritual and emotional quest of finding
out who he was that took priority over
him returning to the asgardians because
in a lot of ways beta ray bill's
character had progressed on such a
personal and emotional level that
ironically enough as angry as fans were
back in the 1990s of him being taken
away from the asgardians in a lot of
ways they kind of didn't want to see him
go back now
they wanted to see the sort of personal
journey of beta ray bill as he
progresses and goes through all of this
and so where you saw stories like the
thanos imperative and you saw him you
know dealing with thor the unworthy
following you know his inability to lift
his own hammer and all that kind of
stuff the truth about this is that with
jason aaron's run on thor god of thunder
and so on that betty ray bill just
remained a background character shifting
around from team to team occasionally
teaming up with thor doing a few things
here and there now this has changed a
lot in donnie kate's current run on thor
and the sense that there was a great big
huge conflict when you initially saw
galactus showing up to thor saying the
black winter was coming and that there
were several worlds they had to consume
in order for galactus to possess enough
energy to defeat the black winter that
thor as the all father became the new
herald of galactus vader ray bill stood
in the way of that a fight broke out
between the two and thor destroyed
stormbreaker and so beta ray bill's
weapon was now gone in an effort to make
amends for that what thor did was bring
beta ray bill on as what was essentially
the weapons master of asgard meaning he
was in charge of all the arms and
armament is this vader ray bill being in
a role that's comparable to the old walt
simonsen days when he fought honorably
alongside thor he had his own hammer
that kind of a thing no it's just the
gradual shift of his character now
knowing donnie cates that will likely
change and beta ray bill will be
elevated to a highly significant role
because donnie cades is nothing if not
an avid comic book fan you can just tell
by his writings but he always builds up
to a bigger role and so the position
that beta ray bill has now really feels
more like donnie cates is just kind of
holding him there until he gets to the
point in his writing when he wants to
basically bring out the big guns bring
out beta ray bill have some great big
huge moment but beyond that that's the
story of him right i mean there are some
things we left out here right beta ray
bill's dealings with jane foster but
we'll talk about that when we make a
video that explains jane foster thor
because while we have covered her
stories we've never done a proper video
for those individuals who don't have
time to watch all of her stories and are
just looking for a more straight-up
explanation of her character and her
publication history but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace